this is a
shard
from a pot about 10 000 years old
i was found by archaeologists at a
chinese site called jiahu
which is a really interesting
archaeological site it has some of the
oldest evidence of rice being eaten as
food it has some of the oldest musical
instruments it has some of the oldest
written language it's a really rich site
this pot when they found it had some
weird residue
inside it which eventually made its way
to an analytical chemist named patrick
mcgovern is it pen
mcgovern ran a whole bunch of tests
feigl spot tests gas chromatography mass
spectroscopy
uv beams shot lasers at it did
everything he could in his
lab
and eventually found
the ingredients
of that residue
so he found three things he found
essentially oils from beeswax which only
comes from one place you get that from
honey
he found evidence that rice had been
pulverized in the pot
and he found tartrate starteric acid
um so for anywhere else at any other
time that would probably meant grapes
which are really high in that stuff
but while there were some wild grapes in
china ten thousand years ago
they
there weren't that many and they
they weren't vetus minifera which is the
only species that we used to make wine
from but they probably were more likely
was hawthorne fruit
which is uh
i asked him what that would taste like
he said it was like a chalky apple
basically but it's but it was fruit and
what
what mcgovern realized he had
he didn't find ethanol i should say
as i mentioned it's really volatile it's
evanescent you never find evidence of
the actual booze you just find kind of
the evidence of the evidence but
mcgovern put all that stuff together in
his head and as he says you'd have a
hard time not letting that ferment if
you mix all those things and left it in
a pot it would want to ferment on its
own just because of yeast in the
environment
this pot
held the mother eve of booze
this is humanity's oldest known
intentionally alcoholic beverage
ten thousand years
uh think of the ingredients it's rice
like in sake right it's honey like in
mead
it's fruit like in a wine all mixed
together
this is the oldest evidence that we have
of us
trying to make something good to drink
right
um
he uh
i asked him if i could hold it
and he um
it's just in his office it's on his
shelf
but i said i could hold it he got very
nervous
and he took out nitro gloves
i put the gloves on but i but i got to
hold on to it and it's i've never held
anything that old before it was
very profound this connection to
somebody else who just tried to make
some stuff you know home brewer right
um
but that's how long we've been doing
this at least right harnessing this
natural process to do what we want it to
do this is us domesticating yeast while
yeast domesticates us please give me
more sugar so i can make you this thing
that you like
[Music]
you